και πολύ γιατρία λεγαμα τώρα κάνομ κιπουριακά φάρμα κάτι δεν είναι ευολο πράμο να επιστεψει
κανείς καλιπά αλλά ακολουθούσαμε ευθύις εξαρχής τα υροτα ευρωπαϊκά προτπα τα αγγλικά τότε και εργότερα
τα ευρωποϊκά πρώτημα τα οποία ακολουθούμε σε όλα μας τα εργοστάσια που διποτις τον κόσμο
όπως είπάμε επιτυχημένος επιχειρμάτιας σε ότι αφορά τη φάρμαμο καιόπμηχανια υπουργή γίασε κύρια πίτα σα
σε έχουν ζητήσει τη βοήθεια γύρο από θέματα οσχελίζονται με αυτό που κάνετα υ πουργείεία
στυναρχήήτα εντελώσαμε τοχή στην αρχή δεν τους ένιαζε πουλύ ευτότ τον πράγμα ούτε ήταν όλοι
συνδρομητές του έργουν μας κατα κάποιον δρόπο οι υπουργί όμως τελευταία άχισε ναδείχνουε διαφέρον θυμαμε
πολύ έντονα και τον κύριο κονστανδίνο ιοάνου και τον κύριο πουργουρίδη οι οποία σύγγουρ λεγόν
τους αν πολλές φορές οι πολλά πράγματα που αφορούσα φάρμακα γεδικά ομοιο βραστικά πάγμακα οι
ενώσημα φάρμακα τα οποία προσφέρουν φτυνότερε στη μές και φυσικά είναι μια μεγάλι αγοά και
καθιερομένοι αγορά πλέον και το γεσί τα χρησμοποιί ευρέος εσας κυριπ σας έγινε πότε πρόταση
να υπουργοποιηθείτα με συχοθς ναιαλλά ποότέ δεν δεκτικά που έχει γίνι διοφορές του κι βάλλιστα
από διάφορες βλευυρές από άλλες πληυρές αά δεν είμαι πολιτικός πότε γιναν αυτές η προτάσει
το μόνο